ahora se llama ley de defensa de los
principios republicanos la palabra
separatismo ha sido borrada del título
del texto 57 artículos que han recorrido
un largo camino desde que emanuel manjón
presentó su plan a principios de octubre
desde entonces tres atentados de
islamistas radicales han golpeado el
país como medidas principales del
proyecto en primer lugar la lucha contra
el odio en línea con la creación de un
nuevo crimen el delito de poner en
peligro la vida de otros al difundir
información privada de unión es un doy
un ejemplo público en las redes sociales
fui controlado por un policía su hija
está en tal escuela en la ciudad se
convierte en un delito y esto antes no
existía salsa dulce trino faction está
listo para eso es lo que le pasó al
profesor asesinado cambio el patch y
cuyo nombre y dirección de la escuela
había sido publicado en facebook este
nuevo delito será castigado con tres
años de prisión y una multa de 45.000
euros la ley también prevé que se
condene la intimidación a los
funcionarios públicos aquí también se
crea un nuevo delito para aquellos que
atacan a una gente por motivos
religiosos
o ideológicos de los padres que van a
ver a un profesor para decirle deje de
enseñar caricaturas la libertad de
expresión mañana será un delito penal
el proyecto de ley también prevé el fin
de la escolarización en casa para los
niños de 3 a 16 años excepto por motivos
muy limitados así como un control
reforzado de las escuelas sin contratos
con el estado con la posibilidad de
cierre administrativo en caso de
infracciones graves y repetidas los
lugares de culto musulmanes tendrán que
ser más transparentes en términos de
contabilidad y finanzas las donaciones
extranjeras de más de diez mil euros en
particular serán sometidas a un declarar
la procedencia de esos recursos